i am so happy do you want to know why
because jehovah god
has given me the bible in asl
which is sign language to help me
understand
a 15-year labor of love jehovah's
witnesses released the first american
sign language bible to the deaf
community
in early 2020 a translation milestone
inspiring organizations
and the local community for us it's been
a 15-year journey
and we can finally say uh it's complete
it's so exhilarating to be able to have
the entire bible
in asl i enjoy being able to watch it
to research it's it's all ready for me
there when it wasn't translated into
american sign language i had to wait
so long and i waited patiently until it
was completed
almost 900 000 complete bibles
have been downloaded uh 2.4 million
complete bible books have been
downloaded and 41 million
individual chapters of this asl
translation have been downloaded
so it's affected many many more than
just jehovah's witnesses because in this
country
those who speak asl those who use asl
only amount to about 10 000 in
congregations of jehovah's witnesses
and only about 2500 of them are actual
deaf from the deaf community the rest
are those who support them in their
congregations
sign language translation is unique the
visual language requires translation
from text to video
his image of what the bible is trying to
say to us
should be the same as a person reading
the bowl in english or any other
language
as a sign language interpreter here in
nevada i work very hard to try and give
an accurate interpretation
but interpreting is kind of like art
you're doing it without
having information beforehand versus the
effort that goes into a translation like
the new world translation
the bible provided for the deaf
could not have come at a better time the
asl bible team were the first to use a
live review panel to ensure a high
quality product that was easy to be
understood by the viewer
so when they when they did a translation
of a text
that was so literal that would it could
only be understood literally
it was often very illogical and it often
meant that the sign language translation
team had to go back to the drawing board
and come up with a revised text that
would be more understandable
our translation system is more thought
for thought rather than
word for word so the concept they're
making sure there's no
missing context concepts or added
concepts
but if that thought can be conveyed in
an accurate way in a meaningful way
that's what it's all about
members in a local sign language
congregation here in las vegas shared
their thoughts on how they felt after
viewing the american sign language bible
for the first time
as a child of two deaf adults i identify
linguistically and culturally with the
deaf community
what i choose to do for my secular work
is i'm an american sign language
interpreter
but as one of jehovah's witnesses i
choose to use the bulk of my time
focusing on a career in teaching the
bible over the years that has been very
difficult
at times because having access to the
bible
in written form doesn't reach their
hearts in the same way as watching it
especially in the last few months well
the last year really because of the
pandemic the isolation is more severe
for members of the deaf community and so
their mental health their emotional
health
has been impacted and so having access
to these
bible scriptures which bring comfort is
is a huge
joy to see hello
my name is richard my name is sign like
this
i am eight years old and i am deaf as
the father of a deaf son
and as immigrants when we moved here
to the united states it was very
difficult in 2019
we moved here to the city of las vegas
and received
great support so we decided to move to
an american sign language congregation
so we could help our son
the very fact that this is the first
bible it's available
freely to anyone who wants to use it
even if they don't agree with what we
say about the teachings of the bible
at least they've got god's word
amazingly the translation work was
carried out by nearly 100 volunteers
the new bible has had a huge impact in
my family in so many ways
in our relationship as a family in me as
a wife
and as a mother now when we all three
sit down to study
the bible we can understand the
questions our son
asks us and i feel a direct connection
with my son
when it comes to reading the bible
watching it in asl i have it downloaded
in an
app on my phone and tablet so i can use
it for study it's
it's all there for me i can use it for
everything that i need
and i love having it there it's just
ready to go
the complete bible in american sign
language or asl is available
for viewing free of charge on their
official website jw.org
and this is really the goal the goal of
jehovah's witnesses
is to get out the gospel the good news
especially
the bible in the language of people's
hearts
reporting from the eight news now
digital news desk i'm your life producer
rocky nash for the full story visit
eightnewsnow.com